[Music]
who wouldn't want to own a castle and
here there are plenty to choose from
over 700 in total it's a place straight
out of a fairy tale but it's turned into
a nightmare for developer misery Adeline
because no one wants to live here he
dreamed up the idea of building these
chateau style villas some 200 kilometers
east of the Turkish capital Istanbul
we're here in the turret that every
villa has from your owners can enjoy the
view of the natural landscape they also
have a nice overview of the estate we
have our Arab friends in mind as buyers
and we've seen how they've been keen to
invest money in our country in recent
years but yeah Dylan's dreams haven't
come true because the Arabs have stayed
away 200 million u.s. dollars had been
sunk into the project before the
developer filed for bankruptcy last year
it's just one of many real estate
projects that have gone bust in Turkey
but yeah Dylan isn't giving up he's
counting on help from above turkish
president richard taya Parowan has
assured us that after the local
elections on march 31st or by next year
at the latest the economy will recover
and the real estate sector in particular
will experience an upswing pagina that
we believe it is generous
but others have little faith that
turkeys housing market will recover on
the contrary the building boom which had
been fueled by low interest rates and
cheap credit has come to an end
experts say developers lost all sense of
proportion and built far more homes than
needed now in times of high inflation
and a weak Turkish lira the industry is
suffering compared to the previous year
new home sales have collapsed the number
of mortgages issued has fallen by close
to 80 percent that's led to massive
layoffs in the construction industry one
in every six people there has lost his
job some 2 million people are employed
in this sector you can imagine the
seriousness of a situation the borscht
ababbas housing development was also
supposed to create lots of jobs but in
neighboring mood ulu people had long
viewed the chateaux project skeptically
the town is known for its traditional
timber houses not concrete chateaus
local historian Mamie Jung toke lives in
a 200 year old timber house that he is
lovingly restored he's proud of
Madonna's artisanal traditions in this
house not even the nails come from a
factory a blacksmith made them with
hammer and anvil so it angers him that a
Disneyland style housing development for
foreigners has been built just a few
kilometers away the people of module new
view it as a threat to their
centuries-old traditions and values
there's still a sense of community here
we help and support one another how can
we pass on our traditions and values to
the next generation when thousands of
people whose only connection to this
place is a real estate investment settle
here
yet it's likely no one will ever move in
here borscht ababbas looks set to become
a ghost town to keep that from happening
misery Evelyn is selling these chateaus
for just three hundred and fifty
thousand euros apiece he still hopes to
attract buyers who want to feel like the
king of the castle